come on looney draymond green the
starters for the dubs
[Applause]
got deandre hunter on him his body
didn't stay connected looney the
offensive rebound off the pool missed
[Applause]
one of the great back quotes with gary
payton the original
[Applause]
[Applause]
he's too good a player
[Applause]
set the screen for curry
three as soon as he gets back in
[Applause]
staff split the double
dropped it off
[Music]
steph leads the defense better than
anybody too though
he met on curry all the time
he lined that one up two defenders
chose to run out to the corner don't set
a screen for steph let him work on
herder
like that
finding that compete level
and their leader
is doing it all
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
need
[Music]
[Applause]
probably didn't see that contact so he
can't blow the whistle
perry for three
this is the step three again no one
close enough to draymond so steph comes
off there quick john collins and capela
trying to work together trying to run it
back
[Applause]
[Applause]
duke that's what they were excited about
his shot making abilities especially
[Applause]
he's feeling himself as he should
[Applause]
in and out was mean he knew herder was
not going to be able to stop
the ball handling what did you call
having that thing on a string you don't
even have to think about your moves just
use your creativity let your mind be
free peyton will push
can you expand this lead step three
[Music]
lead i'm going at herder's head this
dude cannot guard me
off the dribble
there's the double team he gets rid of
it jta for three
let's see little ball fake to gary
payton the second in the corner
[Applause]
at bottom no air space steph's saying i
don't need much air space
such a quick release
andrew wiggins
a lot of screens to knock hayton away
from the good work but behind the back
has
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
50 pieces
handle any kind of punishment
and
you got two defenders all around the
third defender comes just keeps working
i know i can get around these two
defenders delon wright just going to
swipe at it